- What is up, BelieveNation?
It is just seven o'clock in the morning
on I don't know what day it is,
but today is Sage Summit day
here in Toronto and
I'm taking you with me.
(upbeat music)
So Sage is one of my clients.
We've had Stephen Kelly on the channel
lots and lots and lots and lots of times.
He's a visionary CEO, one of
my favorite CEOs in the world
and every year they put
on these huge events
to celebrate entrepreneurship
and this year they have one
in Toronto so I am going
and going to have some fun.
Let's do it.
(upbeat music)
So typically Sage Summit
has been in one main city
and last year I went, past
two years I've went and spoke.
This year they're going to multiple cities
so I'm here in Toronto for
their tour which is awesome
and Lily and I are also going
to be taking part in it.
We have sessions today
and tomorrow mentoring
some of the entrepreneurs
that are showing up,
so I'm pretty pumped.
I love mentoring and helping entrepreneurs
and it's Lily's first
time at the Sage Summit
so I'm excited to see her energy too.
(upbeat music)
I just saw Lily.
I'm going to go find her.
Look who I found, it's Lily.
- It's Evan.
- [Evan] She's filming.
Oh yours says new to Sage, look at that.
- [Lily] Yeah.
- [Evan] Alright.
- Maybe people will be
nicer to me (laughs)
- Lily and I got here early.
Room is about to get full.
We got our front row seats.
Look at that.
(triumphant music)
Alright, just came out
of the, what was that,
key note session part.
Lily was dancing a lot.
Kind of.
And I found the troublemaker,
the troublemaker.
Rebecca Coleman.
- If you have a video camera
I have to photo-bomb you,
that's the rule.
That is a rule, I didn't
make it, I just observe it.
- She's doing a session on ABCs
of social media here today.
What's a tip?
Number one tip from Rebecca
Coleman on social media?
- Consistency.
If you want to be
successful on social media,
you just got to keep doing it.
- What is consistency?
- Like every day.
- Once a day?
- Maybe not for every single network,
but yeah, you got to keep doing
it consistently or else...
That's 90% of the battle right there.
- Or else, this happens.
- 90% of the battle right there,
like you just got to keep doing it.
- Rebecca Coleman everyone.
Next up, Lily and I are
doing our mentoring sessions.
- Yes we are!
- Lily's pumped.
We're going to go help some entrepreneurs.
I'm excited, too.
(upbeat music)
Alright, it's lunch time.
Time to get some food.
So I had a fan of the channel, Sebastian,
come up and interrupt the
conversation we're having
and he is trying to write a book
and trying to build his business
and wanted feedback on Your One Word,
how to apply it to his
life for what he's doing
and we have Lily, who is
the Your One Word coach,
so she just started a session with him
and I'm excited to see how it turns out.
Fingers crossed he has a big
breakthrough that's coming.
I'm excited for them.
(upbeat music)
Alright, that ended up
being a crazy day one.
I was B-rolling Lily doing
some coaching sessions
and then I got bombarded with
people who wanted to meet
and get advice and so
didn't even have time
to set up the camera,
no B-roll no nothing.
Just helping entrepreneurs.
One story that was awesome
was there was a girl
who started a business and
saw my YouTube channel,
watched every video, and
was thinking about coming
to Summit, got an email, thought oh,
it's about accounting, I'm not interested,
and then saw that I was
speaking at the event
and she said I got to go,
I'm going to go and see Evan
and that felt good and
I hope she got value.
I hope she got good value.
I hope I didn't let her down, there.
But it's great to connect with fans,
great to help some entrepreneurs.
I've got to leave.
Lily's still doing some mentoring.
I'm going to go pick up Hayden from school
and then I will be back again tomorrow
for day two of Sage Summit,
helping more entrepreneurs.
Alright, day two of Sage Summit.
This is Aleks.
Aleks has our message of the day.
- Today's message is hustle
even when you don't want to.
- Hustle even when you don't want to,
that's good, that's a good
message for you too (laughs)
- [Aleks] I'm hustling.
Hustling to get some coffee right now.
- Aleks is not coming
today but I'm heading off,
Lily's doing a session,
I'm doing a couple.
We're going to have some fun.
(upbeat music)
Alright, so I made it in.
Got my coffee.
Back in my mentor lounge seat here.
I got my name tag.
I'm supposed to do one session today
but apparently there's a line up
of people who want to chat
so they smushed three people
into my one session and on my break,
I'm talking to somebody else too, so...
I love it.
I don't like breaks, like let's go.
You want to help entrepreneurs, I'm here,
I'm pumped, I'm ready to do it.
I'm waiting for Lily to come
and then, first session,
I don't know if I'm going to
have time to shoot any B-roll
while I'm making it, maybe
Lily will, we'll see,
but being able to help entrepreneurs
is what gets me fired up.
Had a couple good sessions.
Just found a good friend of mine,
Roger Pierce, going to go say hi.
He's about to give a presentation.
It's Mr. Roger Pierce.
There he is.
- Hi, Evan, how are you?
- What are you talking about?
- We're doing professional
tips to close more sales,
following the seven steps of selling.
- What's your favorite step?
- The close, overcoming
those nasty objections
to get the customer to sign
the line that is dotted.
- What's a piece of
value that you could drop
on BelieveNation around closing?
- Don't be afraid to ask for the sale.
You'd be surprised how
many entrepreneurs quiver,
don't want to ask the customer to proceed.
Ask for the sale if you
think you've earned it.
- I like it.
So lunch is Asian
chicken noodle something,
beef pilau, burrito, although
I don't see a burrito.
Maybe I missed that.
And a fruit stick.
Yeah, time to eat.
Alright, had a couple more great sessions.
Awesome vibe here.
So many great entrepreneurs.
I love entrepreneurs.
It's always great helping
them out, but I'm late.
They are overbooking me
and then on my breaks
they wanted me to meet more people
and as I'm leaving more people
come up to ask questions
so I was like I got to go, I got to go,
so I'm heading off to the
media center upstairs.
Supposed to do a Facebook
live hangout with Stephen
then I think I have a little bit of time
and then doing the live
YouTube hangout with you guys,
so super pumped for that.
This is where we're going to do it.
We got the set up.
Me and Stephen in the middle.
CN Tower on one side,
City Hall on the other.
Excited for some Facebook live.
- Great to have a live broadcast
from Sage Summit in Toronto.
There's a couple thousand entrepreneurs,
business partners here,
and we'll tell you a
bit about Sage Summit.
We might go for a walk
and go see the show floor
during the broadcast as
well, but most of all,
I'm really privileged to
be joined by an old friend,
an amazing entrepreneur, author, inspirer.
Many of you know him and
you've seen him on his channel.
Evan Carmichael.
So Evan, great to be in
you home city, Toronto.
- I love it.
I'm glad you guys came here
on the Sage Summit tour.
It's great, I can just wake up
and come right downtown to
Sage Summit, it's awesome.
Alright, we had a fun
Facebook live hangout.
Got to explore the floor as well,
go chat with some entrepreneurs.
Next up is our Google live
hangout with you guys.
Just setting up here.
Testing the connection,
make sure we got a good one
and looking forward to
answering your questions.
Stephen's rocking some Canadian pride.
We've got the Canada pin happening there.
Oh there's Sage at the top, too!
I didn't see that!
There's a little Sage logo at the top.
The cuff-links.
You can't see his shoes,
he's got the shoes.
He's got the tattoo happening on the arm.
- (mumbles) Here we are.
Upside down, sorry guys, here.
- There it is, look at that.
There it is, Canada flag.
- There it is, can you see it?
Canada flag.
Can't get my arm around.
- Alright, we are done.
That was awesome.
There were so many questions coming in,
I couldn't keep track.
Normally on the hangouts that I do,
while the other person's talking,
I'll scroll through the questions
and look for the next one,
but I didn't want to look
offscreen all the time
and feel like I was ignoring
what Stephen was saying,
so I was going through it,
but I looked at a question
and then I came back and
the question was gone
'cause the page filled with new questions
and so it was awesome
to see the interaction.
Love you guys, so many great
questions, so much fun.
I just feel bad that people
posted some questions
multiple times and I saw it
and then when I came back
to read it, it was gone
and I went to another one, so...
Just be persistent guys,
get your questions in early
and often and hopefully next time
we'll be able to answer them.
That's it for me.
It's been another amazing Sage Summit.
Going to head home, catch Nina,
do our workout and enjoy
the rest of my week, so...
Appreciate you guys for watching.
Hope you enjoyed.
Maybe I'll see you at a event soon
and just one quick thing.
If you're going to events,
and you want to meet
people, get in there fast.
You want to go talk to a speaker?
Be there before the speaker goes on stage.
You want to have a mentoring session?
My first mentoring session was empty.
Nobody showed up.
I spoke with Lily for 45 minutes.
And then at my next mentoring
session it was all full
and the next one it's like triple booked
and getting people wanting
to talk to me on my break
and walk me to the next thing,
and it's great, I'm happy to do it,
I love being fully booked.
I'm not complaining, I
love it, it fuels me.
But there were lots of people waiting too,
who I didn't get to talk to
and it bothers me because I
had all this free time before.
And so if there's someone who you want
to talk to at an event, don't be shy.
If your goal is to go
there and talk to them,
get their feedback on something
that you're dealing with right now.
Don't be shy. Go say hi.
Talk to the speaker
before they go on stage
because they're going to
be bombarded afterwards
and even if you do get in,
they're only going to have
a couple minutes because they're swamped,
there's a huge line up.
For the hangouts that I just did, right?
Be the first one there.
The guy who asked the first question,
I answered his question, right?
It was the first question in.
All the other people who join later,
you know, there's a chance we answer it
and there's a chance we may not
and then we're rushing trying
to get through other questions
so if there's something
that you want to do,
there's somebody that you want to meet,
and you know they're going to be there,
they're doing a hangout,
just show up early.
Ask the question, be the first one there.
It makes such a huge difference
between getting results and not and so,
just going to leave you with that, guys.
Hope you have an amazing weekend.
Thank you for watching,
thank you for all the love.
I really appreciate it.
You guys are the reason why I do all this
and I'm really thankful for
your support and viewership
so that's it for me.
Continue to Believe in
whatever your one word is.
Much love guys.
I'll see you soon.